so that was nina jankowicz we just told
you the head of the ministry of truth
already she's being sued by the way the
states of missouri and louisiana have
just filed a lawsuit against the
administration including officials like
jankowitz for colluding with big tech to
censor speech which they are doing the
bite administration does it in public
they've repeatedly called on facebook
twitter other platforms to censor
opinions that are critical of them eric
schmidt is the attorney general of
missouri he's the top law enforcement in
that state he's joined the suit he joins
us tonight mr general thanks so much for
coming on tell us why you're suing
well look we're taking on we're fighting
back against the two of the most
powerful and corrupt institutions that
are out there big government in big tech
for colluding working together
suppressed speech and they do it a
couple different ways tucker they hold
over these special protections like
section 230 protections unless they
censor more they also have been very
outspoken jinsaki's talked about how
they're flagging posts now in july of
last year flagging posts for facebook as
disinformation so they're working
directly with them we know that and then
now this newest orwellian chapter this
dystopian chapter of the ministry of
truth i mean you have mary poppins in
charge of this thing i guess now and
that would be like putting by the way
carella deville in charge of uh managing
an animal shelter it's a total disaster
okay these folks are nuts they're intent
on suppressing speech that they don't
like calling it disinformation
misinformation so we're filing a lawsuit
and tucker you talk about this all the
time the reality is
individuals have a right to speak their
mind this is at the core of the american
experiment that this is a god-given
right government's there to protect
those rights not to tell you what you
can say and when you can say it so this
lawsuit it's a landmark lawsuit we're
going directly after the collusion uh
they're working together to suppress
speech and we're fighting back
so just as quick as a constitutional
matter government cannot encourage
censorship that's a direct i mean we
know that through the supreme court many
rulings over the years that's the
violation the first amendment correct
yep that's exactly right and what we're
arguing in this case tucker is that
they're outsourcing that
the government is outsourcing the
censorship to their big tech partners
they're flagging it and by the way
they're terrified when we get into
discovery here and find out how jinsaki
and fauci and ma you know mary poppins
here are working with the big tech
partners what they're asking what
they're telling to take down we know
it's the laptop from hell we know it's
the origins of covid we know it's the uh
you know ineffectiveness of mass we know
all of these things that they've been
working with them on in this lawsuit
will help bring those the light and
expose it and that's why it's important
case
mr attorney general i appreciate you
coming on tonight good luck thank you
thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight